there is growing intrigue surrounding
the British royal family after an
unprecedented announcement from Prince
Harry and his wife Megan Markel the
couple says that they are stepping down
as senior members of the family and plan
to raise their baby son Archie in both
the UK and North America now Megan
talked about her life and possibly
wanting a change in life during an
interview last October it's not enough
to just survive something right that's
not the point of life you've got a
thrive you've got to feel happy and I
think I really tried to adopt this
British sensibility of a stiff upper lip
but I think that what that does
internally is probably really damaging
Tina Brown is the author of the Diana
Chronicles she has covered the royal
family extensively good morning to you
Tina Brown good morning well the tabloid
headlines and newspaper headlines in
Britain are very harsh Wow such decision
yeah it's a big wow sir what is your
take well she's being eviscerated yeah
my feeling is honestly I I think I'm
maybe I'm not common this view but I
kind of think that she's ripped off they
they both have sort of rip the band-aid
off earlier than anybody quite expected
to me this was inevitable this this you
know direction that they've moved in but
I thought it might come in two years
three years I'm quite surprised that it
happened at such warp speed but all of
the signals coming out of the palace for
the last six months have been an
accelerated pace of consolidating where
the royal family is going to be post the
death of so much talk though there's so
much talk about the the Queen and the
palace being blindsided that's the
reporting in the paper that's reporting
that it's true yeah I don't think that's
true I think it's true I find it very
hard to believe that the palace the
Queen didn't have some idea or some
knowledge that this was coming and that
this was going to be coming the way that
it son but I think we're surprised about
every fully aware that this sabbatical
they were taking was really about
thinking whether they wanted to be in or
out they had they went away to think
that through
and I'm absolutely sure that the royal
family knew that that was the case I
think that where they may have been
surprised was the timing of the
announcement before all the details have
been properly worked out because there
are a lot of quote details I mean you
can't really step back I mean do you
remember in the 90s when Princess Diana
made that famous speech I think she was
at a charity somewhere and she said I'm
going to now retire from public life and
for quote time and space and of course
you can't get time and space you can't
be a part time global celebrity you're
in or you're out
yeah and I think that's going to be the
difficult part I think that desiring to
be have their own life is absolutely
probably the right decision for these
two people you can't really be a
part-time Prince it's hard to be a
part-time Prince because of all the
issues of you know the Commonwealth
funding the row and the tours which they
say I think the you know the government
funding those Commonwealth tours which
they obviously want to continue to be
able to do the house on we know from
more where they live
you know the the funding that they get
from Prince Charlie when they say when
they say they're gonna work to be
financially independent when they're
gonna work to be what does that mean do
you think I think what it really means
is that Megan particularly and I think
now Harry feel they can't stand the
constraint they have I mean this is a
fully evolved working woman of 38 at
this point and yet there's all of these
layers of permission on anything that
she can do they can't just say I want to
do this I want to do that they have to
go through all these palace layers
they've got you know Charles on top of
them they've got the Queen on top of
them they've got you know you know with
him on top of them and you know it's
it's unbearable I think that what megan
has desired for time and I know she has
felt strongly this is like getting back
some control of her life she feels she
has no control but is it wrong to want
to be financially independent and still
support the Queen and support the
monarchy can't you do both you can as a
kind of outside sort of celebrity as it
were but the question of whether or not
you're going to be a fully funded other
foreign office going to fund all their
tours and so on when they're also making
money in other ways that's never really
been done I can't have two jobs in
effect no and and and it confuses and
alienates the British public if they
feel that you're a celebrity who sort of
coining a lot of money and on one level
and then suddenly you switch into being
a royal prince who's you know being
funded by the government to go on
Commonwealth cheers to know with with
this and with the effective exile of
Prince Andrew in the aftermath of the
Jeffrey Epstein debacle interview where
is the royal family at this moment the
royal family are absolutely slimming
down I mean Prince Charles has for some
time said that his vision of the royal
family is of a much more close knit you
know essentially editing out the others
no it's just about the heirs and their
and their heirs that's what they want
and in fact there was a very I thought
telling photograph telling incident over
Christmas the Queen Christmas message
where she always people always decode
the photographs on her dress you know
2018 you saw pictures of Harry and Megan
getting married and her granddaughter
you journey by Prince Andrew's daughter
on the also got married picture on the
desk this he and no pictures on the desk
of merit any ears just there's a
photograph that they released just the
four questions which was the four as it
was the Queen Charles you know William
and Prince John little George it was
very cute right
if the palace had known about it and I
actually do think that they did why
couldn't there been a statement of we're
aware of this decision we support their
decision we're working out all the
details as opposed to the messaging that
they sort of went rogue and now
everybody is very upset it could have
been message very different I think you
know in the moment people are aggravated
you know I think that they feel they do
feel blindsided a little bit not by
their decision but by the the fact that
he dropped like I'm like a hand grenade
into the space they did this week see
where it goes you got slimming down of
the royal family stories also not a
thing about who Prince George's dating
don't forget that really the converse
right Tina thank you very much we
appreciate it
you